hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again where we're doing a movie review
forgive me if my voice sounds a little
bit uh funny i have a little bit of a
cold so you know i'm just gonna try and
power through it it's not that bad uh so
but yeah it is making my voice sound a
little bit funny
so if you guys will remember not too
long ago tom and i saw the 2022 reboot
of fire starter
and as i mentioned i think when we
talked about that movie like we didn't
love it but it was like it was okay it
was pretty good
but i remembered that this was actually
only the second feature film directed by
keith thomas
and i also happen to remember that keith
thomas
had made his feature film debut back in
2019 with a movie called the vigil which
actually premiered at that year's
toronto film festival and actually there
was a little bit of a buzz about it
because i remember seeing a lot of um
videos like reviewing it you know on
horror channels i watch and stuff like
that um and i kind of like forgot that
it existed until fire starter came out
and came out and people started like
referring to it so i was actually
curious to see what keith thomas uh had
done with a movie that he both wrote and
directed like rather than it being an
adaptation of someone else's work
so i noticed that the movie was on hulu
so i went ahead and fired it up and gave
it a watch
now i will say the premise of this movie
is not uh all that original it's pretty
much like a haunted house or a demon not
necessarily demon possession but a demon
type of story
but it does have kind of a unique angle
in that the story is set kind of within
the orthodox jewish community
and sort of relies on that mythology uh
for the story
uh the movie overall very very nicely
shot very atmospheric
has some really effective
creepy images and scenes in it
it's a little slow uh it's almost
entirely set in one house which like i
said probably like budget constraint but
you know i don't mind that i don't mind
like a movie that's just set in one
location because i know that is a lot
cheaper and it can be done really well
which i think it is here uh i will say
it relies a little bit too much on jump
scares
but overall
a pretty solid little horror movie
if you're looking for something kind of
like creepy in the lower budget uh
blumhouse sort of thing but with like a
little bit of like i said like a slow
arty kind of thing to it so what you
have uh the actor dave davis plays a
character named yakov ronan now he is a
young man in brooklyn and he's grown up
apparently his entire life in new york
city's orthodox jewish community
now after a tragedy that you don't find
out like what exactly it was like what
the details were until later
uh the audience learns that yakov has
recently left this community now you're
led to believe that i guess he still you
know retains his faith presumably and
he's still it's not like he's shunned or
anything like that like he still lives
in the area he still seems to maintain
contact with friends and family members
things like that but has just apparently
decided this whole orthodox thing is
just isn't for him anymore
so at the beginning we see him in this
course kind of like i'm led to believe
it's like a support group uh for other
people that grew up in ortho orthodox
judaism and now they're kind of getting
out of it and how they're going to like
adapt to
you know the secular world or the world
at large which apparently is like very
difficult for them
so it's really clear that yakov in
particular is struggling i'm assuming i
don't know a great deal about the
orthodox jewish community but they seem
uh you know just from this movie it
seems that yakov is very sheltered and
he doesn't really know how to write a
resume although like he's saying oh i
wrote it by hand and like handed it to
the guy the interview and it's like
obviously i didn't go too well uh he
doesn't really know how to interview for
a job he doesn't really know how to like
talk to women or be social or anything
like that and it appears uh the
implication being
that he's only recently learned to use a
smartphone like he's very excited about
ooh my favorite part it's the flashlight
you know what i mean so because of these
difficulties uh he's having some money
problems unsurprisingly
now on his way out of the meeting we see
somebody is there like waiting for him
so he runs into this guy uh which is
either i don't know if it's a friend or
a relative i saw one review that said it
was his cousin but i don't remember if
he says in the movie that he's related
to him or it was just like a guy he knew
from before
but this guy is named reb shulem
and he's still a member of the orthodox
community
now he knows that yakov is hurting for
cash
and he's like look i got a proposition
for you like tonight there's a local guy
named reuben litvac and he's a holocaust
survivor he uh died today and someone
needs to be what they call i guess it's
either schomer or scheumer i couldn't
tell how they were probably pronouncing
it this is a person that um it well in
general it's somebody that's like
supposed to watch over
something like no matter what it is but
in this context it's somebody who
essentially sits in vigil over the dead
body until the mortuary attendants come
to get it so you're led to believe that
it's kind of like protecting the body
from something protecting the soul
whatever it is they kind of like get
into it a little bit but there has to be
somebody sitting there
now there's actually kind of like a
little bit of text at the beginning of
the movie that explains
that usually uh the person you know
sitting in vigil over the body would be
a family member you you know you would
imagine but uh they said sometimes when
that's not possible like the family
members or friends are not available
then it's perfectly promulent it's
perfectly fine to hire somebody to do it
and indeed it's quite common for that to
happen
so this is essentially what reb shalom
wants yakov to do
he says i'll pay you for well at first
he offers 200 but the yakov is like no
500 and he's like okay 400 so he's like
i'll give you 400
all you have to do is sit at the litvack
house and watch over the corpse until
dawn which is at this point is about
five hours away because it's like almost
midnight or something
he says now reb shulem says the first uh
scharmer i hired uh took off because he
was afraid although that's he didn't say
what he was afraid of and that's like he
doesn't really elaborate on it
uh reb also says that mr litvak uh he's
like his wife is in the house and she's
still alive um but she has dementia and
she kind of goes in and out so she's not
real up to like um sitting the vigil so
they needed somebody else to do it
so yakov kind of uh is kind of reluctant
about this um but he has done it before
and he's like well i do really need the
money
so it doesn't really take too much
coaxing to talk him into it
now reb shalom and we're led to believe
that this isn't the first time this
happens uh then tries to convince yakov
hey after you're done doing that like
why don't you come to morning prayers
with me like on the following morning
like low-key trying to get him back in
the fold he's not obnoxious about it to
be fair but he's just kind of like look
i respect your decision but why don't
you just come with me come on it'll be
fine you'll see everybody and stuff but
jakob is like yeah no i'm not having
that
but to his credit like rep shalom is
like okay fair enough they're like i
said they're not obnoxious about it or
anything like that he's just kind of
show oh come you know come to synagogue
with me and he's just like no i don't
really want to do that
so the rest of the movie takes place
inside the latvix house which is like a
spooky old house you know standard issue
and the body of reuben latvik is lying
under a sheet like in the part in the
front parlor like in front of the front
windows
so as the hours kind of creep by the
five hours that uh that yakov is in this
house
you kind of have these you know those
horror movies sort of like shenanigans
starting to ramp up in the sense that
yakov starts hearing like weird noises
upstairs like somebody walking around
that is maybe too big to be the little
old lady that's up there um he actually
looks over into the dining room which is
all really dark
and he thinks he sees like this shadowy
figure over there in the corner and then
he shines his the flashlight on his
phone that he loves so much over there
and there's nothing there so there's
that um and then he starts here like his
hands start like his joints start
cracking really weird like almost like
he has like arthritis or something like
that so he hears these weird cracking
noises uh which comes into play later on
so there's that
uh and then you know as time goes on and
on like the phenomena just like
escalates into the point where he's kind
of
having what could be like full bore like
hallucinations being like there's one
really gross one that involves a toenail
which i won't really go into there's one
where he's like drinking some water out
of a glass and there's like um it seems
like it turns into hair or something
like that that he's that pulls out of
his mouth there's uh one really really
eerie one where he is because he's kind
of like on his phone even though i think
technically from an orthodox standpoint
you're supposed to just like sit and
vigil and not you know look on your
phone or not do any like technology type
stuff but he's just like doing it anyway
and nobody seems all that bothered about
it
but he's on the phone kind of like
texting this young woman that he's sort
of interested in from his support group
and he gets a video like from an unknown
number and i'm not gonna say what's on
the video but it's like it's pretty
creepy it's like it's low-key but it's
like pretty creepy like the way it's
done so yeah so that's pretty spooky
now the movie does actually introduce a
little bit of ambiguity in the sense
that
there's one scene where yakov is calling
his doctor
and he's talking about the medication i
think he says he's out of van and saying
well i you know it's getting bad but i
don't think that i'll have that i'll
have to go back to the hospital so you
know implying that you know he had some
like a nervous breakdown or something
like that before
so it's also kind of like showing the
audience well is the stuff that he's
seeing
is that really real or is it just like
um a product of like his past trauma
which actually you do find out what that
is like through kind of nightmares that
he has and flashbacks that he has which
kind of involves sort of the sort of
horrific death of a family member of his
that he actually feels uh responsible
for or guilty about
but uh okay so there's that but like the
upshot of all this though
is that you find out that the dead guy
reuben latvik who was a good guy he was
he wasn't like evil or nothing like that
but he was plagued throughout his life
by a demon
of essentially of jewish folklore which
is called a magic
now this thing uh mrs latvik like tells
yak about it later on
this demon apparently like attaches
itself to people in that are in a great
distress or great psychological pain and
like feeds off of them
uh and now that reuben has died
the magic is looking for a new host
and since yakov has been in the house
and the demon is apparently floating
around in the house like looking for
another one and because yakov has this
terrible trauma like in his recent past
and is you know kind of having a hard
time getting his [ __ ] together uh the
magic is going to be like latching on to
him and basically
will never leave him alone we'll like
dog him his entire life unless there's a
specific thing that you have to do like
to get rid of it i don't think you can
kill it but like you can get it off you
essentially
uh i will say too that the way the demon
looks is super cool i really do like
it's like really [ __ ] creepy like he
has like these really big like creepy
hands which are kind of cool but i like
the whole conceit and this is maybe a
little bit of a spoiler alert but the
whole conceit of him his head being on
backwards i thought was like really
really cool i really like that this is
like really really unsettling like the
look of it
now as i mentioned uh the vigil it's not
breaking any new ground uh in terms of
the supernatural horror genre or the
demon possession or haunted house genre
but i will say that it's pretty
refreshing to see like a demon
possession style movie that isn't based
around catholicism for a change uh and i
can't really think
of that many other
horror films that deal with orthodox
jewish folklore in the way that this one
does i mean really i looked on wikipedia
and there's some
i mean they just listed films that were
about uh you know orthodox jewish
community but a lot of them weren't
horror movies so this is really kind of
like a refreshing uh spin on it you know
it's kind of cool to see a different
spin on you know what's essentially kind
of like a formula type of horror movie
so the movie isn't like reinventing the
wheel or anything like that uh it does
succumb to a few kind of cliche horror
tropes and sometimes like a little bit
like i said look over reliance on jump
scares or musical stings or things like
that like you know a lot of blumhouse
movies do that
because that's i think this is imc ifc
midnight distributed this but i think
blumhouse was had something to do with
it as well but overall uh this was like
a pretty decent watch um had some pretty
effective
uh creepy atmosphere and some like
really cool like spooky imagery that i
was kind of into and like i said it's
kind of nice to see a different take on
sort of the same old same old and i kind
of like haunted house movies and movies
like this so yeah it was it was
perfectly it was a perfectly solid uh
movie definitely worth watching if
you're into that kind of thing so you
know it's on hulu at the moment i'm sure
it's probably streaming uh other places
as well so let me know if you've seen it
or what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one bye